bonjour caroline picard merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
on l'a vu un dès aujourd'hui terminée
les cas contacts au sein d'une classe de
maternelle et d'élémentaire comment cet
assouplissement des règles est il perçu
au sein du personnel scolaire
oui bonjour eh bien nous sommes un peu
dans le doute 1 comme je l'entendais
juste avant les parents d'élèves dire
nous nous demandons un petit peu ce
qu'il en est effectivement donc les
comme le fameux partage avec le
ministère l'envi que les écoles et des
places restent ouvertes et dandy de
continuer à enseigner mais cela ne
semble un peu léger d'alléger ce
protocole en particulier à paris où le
virus est plutôt en forte augmentation
car moment régulièrement
est ce que les professeurs et puis le
personnel scolaire se sent en danger
avec cette mesure alors clairement les
enseignants ne se sentent pas assez
protégé d'abord il ya eu la question des
marocains des masques en tissu fournis
par le ministère qui était considéré
comme non protecteur par plusieurs ars
maintenant dans le nouveau traité
protocole il est écrit que d'un coup ils
deviennent protecteur les enseignants
sont inquiets et finissent par acheter
eux-mêmes masques chirurgicaux et ça met
une ambiance un peu difficile dans les
écoles est ce que le corps enseignant
est aussi soutenu par lampard les
parents d'élèves face cet
assouplissement des reines
vous voulez dire dans la l'inquiétude
face à cet assouplissement
oui exactement oui oui j'ai alors j'ai
l'impression plutôt effectivement que
tout le monde y perd un peu son latin il
sait plus très bien qu'en penser et que
les parents d'élèves font globalement
confiance aux enseignants par rapport à
leur analyse de la situation
que faudrait il faire selon vous en cas
de
de caïn positive de kovy 19 parmi les
parmi les élèves aujourd'hui
alors afin selon nous la première chose
c'est qu'il faudrait des réponses plus
rapides parce que souvent quand il ya un
cas positif
les écoles sont censé écrire à la
cellule de crise du rectorat
donc ce qu'elles font et la cellule de
crise ne répond pas ça ne répond pas
assez vite donc le lendemain
mais tout le monde est encore à l'école
dans la tente qu'il y ait une liste
d'enfants peut être confinés où par
confiner d'adultes et c est donc en plus
du risque sanitaire c'est source de
grande inquiétude chez tous les adultes
de l'école
donc il faudrait déjà plus de réactivité
voilà de notre hiérarchie plus de prise
de décision tant pas nous laisser comme
ça un peu un peu perdu à devoir
expliquer aux parents et à entendre ce
qu'on entend de leader tout à l'heure
d'une mère d'élève ma moi j'enlève
peut-être mon enfant après chacun fait
ton côté à sa manière et ça ne forme pas
une bonne idée
alors ça fait un peu plus de trois
semaines que les élèves sont revenus en
classe
comment cela se passe au quotidien quels
moyens et quelles mesures sont mises en
place pour tenter de protéger et le
corps enseignant et les élèves
franchement malheureusement assez peu de
choses en particulier dans les classes
il ya toujours autant d'élèves qu'avant
donc entre 25 et 30 ans va dire par
classe c'est difficile de garder la
moindre distanciation donc sur le
protocole à chaque fois dit écrit si
possible donc si possible distanciation
si possible si possible ce qui veut dire
qu'en fait on fait ce qu'on peut
il ya encore des problèmes d'eau dans
certains dans certaines écoles en
particulier d'école élémentaire pas
assez de regret donc les enfants du mal
à pouvoir se laver les mains on n'a pas
eu de livraison de noël coliques nous
vivons encore sur nos réserves du mois
de mai jean mais quand elles arriveront
à expiration de sais pas ce qu'il en
sera donc plus les fameux masque dont je
parlais avant voilà l'impression de être
protégée n'est pas là et comment les
élèves
vivre cette situation au quotidien est
ce que tous tentent de respecter l les
gestes barrières on sait que c'est
peut-être parfois un petit peu compliqué
notamment pour les plus jeunes d'entre
eux franchement alors autant je pense
que le masque et à le fêter en silence
un masque et nous pensions peut-être se
fera un souci chez les enfants ça l'est
pas tant que ça sans doute depuis que
tout le monde ait masqué aussi à
l'extérieur donc il semble que c'est
plutôt habitué en revanche tout ce qui
est effectivement gestes barrières comme
vous dites lavage leur lavage des mains
ça c'est les distanciation c'est
impossible en particulier en maternelle
mais ça nous l'avions déjà dit le 11
juillet on ne peut pas demander à des
enfants d'être ensemble et de rester à
distance les uns des autres
merci beaucoup caroline pecqueur d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin sur arte france
je rappelle que vous êtes et du syndicat
national unitaire des instituteurs et
professeurs des écoles affilié à la fsu
de paris merci beaucoup